hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outpro and this was
unbelievable Deku has ascended to the
level of a quirk God as he uses all his
quirks together to defy the laws of
physics Deku is pushing the limits of
what is physically possible and time and
space are bending to his will but all
for one in shigaraki are not done yet
and their quirks are about to return
when that happens the clash between Deku
and shigaraki all for one will turn into
a clash of gods and after that the world
will never be the same again so let's
get into it you guys know the drill if
you enjoy rmha content and you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment right now and if you're
new to the channel or maybe you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
remember that subscribing is completely
free and it really helps me out a lot
finally this video will of course
contain mha manga spoilers so please
press seed with caution you have been
warned in the previous chapter we had
that crazy final Quirk reveal for Deku
the name of the second user's Quirk was
officially translated as Transmission in
the viz translation which is the same
name that it had been given in The
Unofficial translation however the
unofficial translation for the new
chapter is now referring to the Quirk as
gear shift so we will have to see if
anything changes with the viz and aiming
until then though I will refer to the
Quirk as Transmission in the last
chapter we also had confirmation that
tomuna shigaraki AKA tenko shimura is
still in there somewhere meaning that
all for one still hasn't been able to
completely unify the new body under his
command this is an important piece of
information that we can't forget because
it will definitely become relevant again
later we also had the second user saying
that shigaraki must be defeated in five
minutes or else the entire world will be
destroyed so there does seem to be a
timer on how long Deku can maintain his
current Godly levels of power finally in
the previous chapter we learned some
specifics about how the final Quirk
Works including its ability to change
the speed of everything that the user
touches including himself transmission
combined with the other quirks like One
for All was able to give Deku the upper
hand against shigaraki and in this
latest chapter deku's domination of the
battlefield continues the new chapter
starts off with a flashback to many
years earlier back when the second user
of one for all was still among the
living in the middle of a war-torn city
all for one who was still in his prime
back then is holding the second user by
the neck and choking him similarly to
how shigaraki was holding bakugou by the
neck and choking him in chapter 360. the
All For One Persona in the present time
can't comprehend why Deku was able to
create such overpowered attacks using
into second user's Quirk because he
remembers this Quirk very differently
all for one remembers transmission as
being a pathetic little peashooter Quirk
that was only able to control the speed
of small objects the second user could
control small objects and launch them at
his opponents but that was basically the
full extent of his power the second user
was nothing but a tiny little bug to all
for one and he successfully squished
that bug many generations ago so why is
this happening now why is Deku suddenly
capable of comfortably overpowering
shigaraki in his final form and why is
he able to use the second user's quirk
in ways that he himself was never able
to do well we of course know the answer
to this question just like every single
Quirk that belonged to a former one for
all user and was later inherited by Deku
transmission grew stronger due to the
effect of one for all one for all is
after all a stockpiling Quirk and it has
been stockpiling power for many decades
and generations and as one for all
became stronger so did all of the quirks
that had been residing inside it
including transmission and not only is
transmission itself stronger but Deku is
also able to use combo quirks such as
using transmission and one for all at
the same time or transmission and fog in
at the same time and so on the end
result of all of this is something
completely different from what all for
one remembers the raw stockpiled power
of one for all combining with
transmission packs enough power to bend
even the laws of physics and this is
showcased in several phenomenal panels
that feature deck who absolutely
outclassing shigaraki on the battlefield
both in terms of speed and in terms of
raw physical power deck was even able to
launch a quintuple Detroit smash at the
villain basic Detroit's matching him
five different times in a matter of
seconds now shigaraki Sasha All For One
Believes that he can counter attack by
predicting where Deku will attack next
even though deku's movements are now too
fast for him to actually see but just
when the villain thinks that he hasn't
figured out Deku suddenly switches into
low gear and he abruptly stops moving
despite the fact that he had just been
moving extremely quickly a moment ago
the second user explains that
transmission allows him to change his
speed while ignoring inertia meaning
that the speed of deku's movement is
literally beyond the laws of physics he
is actually able to change the speed of
things on a cellular level including the
cells of his own body so that means that
our normal understanding of things like
inertia momentum acceleration and
deceleration simply don't apply anymore
Deku then proceeds to showcase the
absolutely amazing ability to smoothly
combine all of his different quirks in
order to add absolutely dominate
shigaraki slash all for one Deku is
using danger sense to Pinpoint
shigaraki's location even as he is using
smoke screen to completely obscure
shigaraki's Vision he then uses float to
rise up into the air and he does this
while also using black whip to reel
shigaraki in finally he uses one for all
fajin and transmission overdrive at the
same time to deliver a devastating
assault on shigaraki as every single
user of one for all throughout history
comes together through their Quirk
factors in order to take down their
common enemy all for one this was
actually a freaking epic moment in the
chapter and one of the most hype moments
in the entire manga all the vestiges
coming together to support the one who
is destined to unlock the full potential
of one for all and finally defeat All
For One izuku midoriya as all the former
users Place their faith in Deku and in
his unlimited determination Deku
declares that he will not allow all for
one to hurt anyone else all for one
slash shigaraki begins to accept that he
doesn't stand a chance against this new
Deku at least not until he can get the
use of all of his quirks back in this
current situation with his quirks being
erased and with his body being trapped
within the floating UA compound all for
one cannot unlock the true potential of
shigaraki's new body and after all this
time of trying to create the perfect
body after all those experiments and
sacrifices that he and ujiko had made
through many generations this is of
course an extremely frustrating
situation for all for one but that is
when something else begins to happen
shigaraki's body suddenly begins to
undergo some sort of hulkification as
his muscles seemingly inflate and expand
rapidly as aizawa notices that the
villain is still up to something all for
one reveals that he still has a chance
to win and then the final panel on the
final page shows spinner and those
mutant Quirk villains that he is leading
and you're probably thinking okay
spinner so what don't tell me spinner is
supposed to be all for one's Only Hope
for succeeding but this is not the
spinner we used to know as we learned in
chapter 353 he seems to have gained some
sort of gigantification Quirk from all
for one in the lead up to the final war
Arc and so he also looks like he turned
into Bane or the Hulk or something and
at the end of the chapter we are all
left to wonder what exactly horikoshi
has planned for us with this whole
spinner thing the hulkification is
definitely a major clue so let's look
into that first we know that spinner and
his villain group have mutant type
quirks and some mutant type quirks are
immune to I Isa was Erasure this is
particularly true of mutant type quirks
that just give their users something
simple like permanent superhuman
physical strength if the villain has a
mutant type Quirk that makes him super
strong or super quick as a permanent
feature of the Quirk then that person
won't be affected by isawa's Erasure so
it is possible that all for one found
some sort of mutant Quirk that is immune
to Erasure and it is this Quirk that
gives its users superhuman strength and
a giant talking appearance it seems that
all for one may have been saving this
Quirk as some sort of Last Resort and
now that he sees that Deku is stronger
than him all for one is forced to use
this last resort showing a spinner could
have been a clue that all for one also
has the same mutant Quirk that spinner
does and this Quirk may be immune to
Erasure but alternatively all for one
may just be planning to summon spinner
and the other mutant Quirk villain
Islands to the floating UA compound so
that they can back him up since aizawa's
Quirk wouldn't work on them and if these
villains can find a way to get to the UA
like for example if they can find
kurogiri and get him to warp them to the
UA they could potentially reach monoma
and force him to break eye contact with
shigaraki Slash all for one if this were
to happen even for a moment then all
bets are off and all options are once
again back on the table I've said this
before but I do believe that all for one
slash shigaraki will eventually find a
way to break monoma's eye contact and
regain the use of all his quirks this
will give us the opportunity to witness
both Deku and shigaraki Sasha all for
one fighting at their absolute strongest
and honestly as Shonen fans we wouldn't
expect anything less from the final
climactic battle of the entire series
with how strong Deku just proved that he
is the only way that shigaraki can
continue to challenge him is by
regaining the use of all his quirks if
he can't do that this battle will be
over very quickly so from a narrative
perspective it seems clear to me that
shigaraki has to find a way to stop
Erasure the only question is how exactly
that is going to happen will spinner and
the other mutant Quirk users manage to
infiltrate the UA and stop isoway and
monoma or does shigaraki Sasha over one
himself have a secret mutant type Quirk
that he has been hiding as a last resort
or will shiraki maybe find some other
type of power up that will allow him to
regain the upper hand in battle we will
have to wait and see but I am fully
expecting to see both the strongest hero
and the strongest villain in history
fighting each other at their absolute
strongest at full power at some point in
the near future now we have to talk
about deku's Evolution and the fact that
he has seemingly become a quirk God now
of course I don't mean an omnipotent
Creator God I mean someone one similar
to a god from say Japanese mythology or
a Greek mythology someone with powers so
incredible that they defy the laws of
physics that everyone else has to abide
by as this chapter revealed Deku already
has reached that point but I don't think
that this is the end of his Evolution
I've been promoting this theory in many
videos but again I have to go back to
Quirk Singularity Deku using all seven
of his quirks against shigaraki was
amazing and it is certainly something
that we haven't seen before from Deku at
least not to this epic extent Deku was
still using seven different quirks he
was using them in combination with each
other he was doing a masterful job
making them work together but they are
still separate quirks one for all is not
called one for all for nothing the
ultimate evolution of the one for all
Quirk will be the fusion of all seven
quirks into a single overpowered super
Quirk that will constitute deku's Quirk
Singularity Deku will attain a new Quirk
Singularity form the quirks will merge
seamlessly into one super Quirk and that
is how Deku will ultimately defeat
shigaraki slash all for one and make no
mistake even though shigaraki recently
attained his new Apex Legend form he
still can't use his quirks so just as
all for one implied shigaraki's body
still hasn't reached its full potential
there will come a time when shigaraki
regains his quirks and attains yet
another Evolution a time when he too
becomes awkward God and when that occurs
the only one who will be able to stop
him is quirk Singularity Deku Deku who
not only uses seven different quirks in
quick succession but Deku who uses one
overpowered super quirk that is the
fusion of all of his quirks into a
single power that at least is my
ultimate theory for how this battle will
end it will be a clash of Quirk Gods
definitely let me know if you agree or
disagree down in the comments below also
why was spinner brought up at the end of
this chapter and what role is he about
to play finally why did the second user
say that Deku has a five minute time
limit and how is this limitation going
to play out in the battle don't forget
to leave your feedback down in the
comments below I always love hearing
from you you guys know the drill if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more mha content in the future leave a
quick like and comment it only takes you
a second but it helps me out a lot with
that YouTube algorithm and of course if
you haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet do me a big favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications subscribing is completely
free but it's a very real way of
directly supporting the channel you can
also also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar big thank you
to all of our anime operator patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thank you to trucker Tim a
disciple of Lord twigo himself and I
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons including Alpha Sigma but they
hefa The Toasted Chi Cory McGowan own
Taylor and Anime s code M finally thank
you to all of our other patrons
including Pro Hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh on Hell Cruise Alicia
actor Fatboy games kaido might be a duck
alivenia Sandy and the school bus if you
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value to you consider supporting
us on patreon or by becoming a channel
member as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys